this is the beginning of part 2 of the
may 20 2015 one it's in another post up
there on patreon the file was too big to
fit in one file Ben Resnick says
assuming many worlds in the time
symmetry of the laws of physics isn't it
always a possibility that a world could
evolve to his previous state and given
that all worlds that could exist do
exist that there will always be a world
which appears to evolve backwards in
time in comparison with our own world or
any particular world for that matter
yeah sure that's possible as long as it
doesn't violate conservation laws and
other basic features but those rule
those worlds are really really really
really really tiny in the wavefunction
so I do not lose sleep over them Paul
Hardy says I've heard it said that the
Big Bang was the beginning of time but
also our universe might be part of a
multiverse or a pocket universe or arose
from something earlier
so wouldn't I'm have had to exist for
that earlier thing to be around yes so
these are two different ideas we don't
know whether the Big Bang was the
beginning of time it might have been
there is a habit in some pop science
circles of taking classical general
relativity that which implies that the
beginning of the universe was a big bang
that had a singularity etc and implying
that that means that the real universe
had a beginning in fact scientists don't
know whether the real universe had a
beginning because there's such a thing
as quantum mechanics and classical
general relativity can't be white right
so there's various ways various physical
mechanisms which you could get a
universe before the Big Bang and we
don't know whether those models are true
or not so either the Big Bang was the
beginning or it came out of something
else in time pre-existed it we're just
not sure crabby smiles says two months
back you took issue with correlating how
low correlating low physical entropy
with low algorithmic information content
do you see no positive relation even
when distinguishing between microstates
the relationship I was trying to draw
was between compressibility of micro
descriptions and entropy low entropy
macro States more tightly constrained
and less provide more information about
the possible microstates the unusual
high entropy microstates compatible with
evolution to a medium entropy present
require stating in detail at high
information cost to a model however we
can effectively spaz
by compatible microstates that happen to
be low entropy simply by giving the
macrostates
so again I'm just not really quite
understanding the the positive statement
being made here I mean maybe there is
some like short actual substantive claim
that I could that could evaluate so let
me say things that I think are true a
macro state that has low entropy tells
you a lot of information about the
microstate that is in it but there are
other ways to tell yourself a lot of
information about the microstate for
example you could have a macro state
that is high entropy but someone says
and in five hours it will be very low
entropy suddenly you could mean enormous
amount of information about that Matt
ghost about that microstate just by
saying something about the future there
is something you can say about how you
can give information based only on
presently available macroscopic
information and relate the amount of
information you get about a system to
its entropy namely the lower entropy the
more the specification of the microstate
gives you that's something I would
certainly agree with Sigurd n cough says
is it conceivable that the universe
could have started in a higher entropy
state if so how might the early universe
have appeared and evolved differently
it's conceivable plenty of things are
conceivable I mean it's conceivable that
the whole universe is a simulation or
that you're a brain-in-a-vat or that we
randomly fluctuated into existence
if the early universe had higher entropy
than it does now that means that all of
its subsequent evolution into the state
that we believe is around us right now
was sort of very unlikely and accidental
and therefore all of our extrapolations
and beliefs and inferences about the
past are completely unreliable
so you really shouldn't believe anything
about what do you think happened in the
past
if that was true and therefore the only
sort of sensible way to go through life
is to believe the consistent story that
says the early universe did have a low
entropy it's been increasing ever since
I can use my hypothesis that the early
universe had a low entropy called the
past hypothesis to make inferences about
the past based on present data Martin
Ziegler says
your interview with probe poker player
live burry you discuss playing game
theoretic optimal have you studied that
yourself and if so do you recommend that
a relative novice study it if not can
you recommend one or two training
tactics that you found to be most
helpful for improving your skills well
so it's important to keep in mind here
that nobody knows precisely what game
theoretical optimal play is for a
complicated game like No Limit Texas
Hold'em with eight players at the table
or something like that you can solve
exactly certain very very simplified
games with two people in them and you
know some very prescribed ways of
actually betting but poker at poker in
the real world is too complicated to
know became theoretic optimal play
really looks like you can try to
approximate it you can do your best but
that's just you know good poker playing
is that and that really things special
about game theoretic optimal playing the
the way that it does become a special
substantive statement is you can
distinguish between game theoretic
optimal play which would be sort of a
dominant strategy in the sense that it
would not lose to any other strategy but
that might not be the best way to play
against a particular opponent real
opponents in the real world are
exploitable because none of them do play
in a game theoretical optimal way so the
best way to play in terms of making
money is typically not in the game
theoretical optimal way because that
optimal way does not take advantage of
mistakes that other people are make or
making if you know that someone is
betting too often you might want to you
know call more of their bets or
something like that
so anyway the the question about
actually playing I think that the kind
of math that is helpful to actually
playing it's pretty easy math you know
there's hard math involved in proving
what it's game theoretical optimal but
there's easy math and figuring out well
I have an ace high flush draw but with
two cards to come they probably have a
pair what is the chance that I'm gonna
win right that's actually very easy math
you just sort of count your out and
compare them to their out set cetera
that's the kind of math you need beyond
that the skills involved in playing are
less about game theory and more
about just taking advantage of your
place at the table and what other people
are doing and getting a good model of
the opponent's you know how likely it is
that they are you know betting with
different kinds of cards so being a good
Bayesian and figuring out what the other
people are actually doing given the
information you have about them that's
the real trick to playing poker and how
to do it some combination of playing
reading books talking to other people
there's great online discussion boards
about poker to read but there's really
nothing better than playing there what
what is sad I think is that there aren't
that many good artificial intelligence
poker programs that you can play against
one of the best ones I found is called
theta poker you can get that for your
iPad or whatever I'm not sure what other
platforms is available for but generally
you know the AIS are not as good as
human beings the poker programs that you
can get are pretty bad most of them out
there Jaden Hammond says what are the
major contending theories for mass
generation of the neutrino which is your
favorite I don't really have a favorite
I'm not an expert on mass generation
theories for the neutrino for those of
you who are not experts you know that if
you did the simplest possible thing when
constructing what we now call the
electroweak theory the electroweak part
of the standard model of particle
physics there's no need to have a
right-handed neutrino in the forces of
nature that we know about namely the
besides gravity electromagnetism the
weak nuclear force and the strong
nuclear force a right-handed neutrino
would not naturally couple to any of
those forces so you can sort of get rid
of it or at least not put it in and have
a consistent theory but if you don't
have that right-handed neutrino you
don't have available to you the
conventional way of giving a particle
mass which is to marry a right and
left-handed neutrino a particle that's
what happens for electrons and quarks
and so forth so you have to be tricky
about giving your particles mass you can
have sterile neutrinos that don't have
any charges at all or you can have what
are called Meyer onna masses that
basically use anti neutrinos as the
right-handed neutrinos so you sort of
marry a left-handed entry
right-handed antineutrino instead and
there's various tricks you can play the
most common thing to do for neutrino
masses or what's called the seesaw
mechanism to have heavy neutrinos with a
very very high mass scale but then they
when they mix together you get some very
very light neutrinos which is what we
actually observe it seems like a very
plausible setup to me but we don't have
the experimental data yet to know
whether it's on the right track Ana
nominal anonymous questioner says help
there's a temporal anomaly in my kitchen
time ticks lower on one side of the room
than the other when I throw a banana
across the room the banana arcs toward
the slow side everything is drifting
toward the slow side of the room I'm
drifting towards the slow side of the
room and when I try to push away I drift
right on back I would like some
intuitions for how time anomalies cause
acceleration intuitions that are more
physically intuitive than bananas
magically move themselves to maximize
their proper time so this is a
complicated setup trying to say you know
if I knew that the metric of space-time
that the curvature of space-time itself
was somehow warped in my kitchen
why do I experience that as gravity I'm
gonna have the same trouble answering
this question that I had to a similar
previous question there's there's two
levels one level is why do particles
move along geodesics right why do
particles work to maximize their proper
time I mean I guess there's a previous
question which is why do geodesics
maximize proper time that's like asking
why is the shortest distance between two
points a straight line and the answer is
you know that's what geometry tells us
I'm not quite sure what to tell you
about that then there's a physics
question why is that there's such
trajectories along which we move you
know you can derive it from equations of
motion from conservation of energy
but again that's controversial or you
can just try to posit it I think maybe
what you're getting at is is there's
some intuitive physical connection
between a change in the so-called rate
at which time flows which again is never
language I would use but people use it
what can I tell ya versus the apparent
force of gravity the fact I feel
something pulling me or pushing me in
one direction and the best I can do
there is sort of analogize because
you're asking for a physical intuitive
explanation
think about the principle of least time
in optics the principle of least time
says that when a light beam goes through
different media so air water glass and
so forth it ends up taking the path that
minimizes the time it takes to go
between one point and another how does
it know how to do that you know I talked
a little bit about this in the biggest
ideas in the universe video on force
energy and action it doesn't know but
what happens is the path along which the
light beam goes changes when it moves
from one index of refraction to another
and an index of refraction can be
thought of as a change in the speed of
light in that medium and you can sort of
summarize all that effect by saying the
particle the photon minimizes the path
that at the time along the path that it
takes so in other words you can trade
off this global statement about
maximizing proper time in relativity for
a local statement that says I just obey
my laws of motion the laws of motion for
a particle is what we call the geodesic
equation which amounts to the same thing
as saying that you move on the closest
you can to a straight line now if you
say well I don't have an intuitive
feeling for why curved space-time gives
me trajectories that are that are not
straight lines then I don't know what to
tell you you know at some point the
intuition only goes so far and you have
to accept with the math and the physics
are trying to say Lothian 53 says if a
particle has a wavefunction that
distributes its location evenly over a
large area then I interact with it by
causing it to take a position in my
world does that mean that for every
point on the wavefunction other worlds
also split off and have their own world
with the particle found at every
possible location yes that is precisely
what it means up to the ambiguity that
we don't know whether there really an
infinite number of such worlds or only a
finite number because we don't know
whether Hilbert space is infinite
dimensional or finite dimensional if
it's finite dimensional there's only a
finite number of worlds that you're
going to get by a process like this Yan
Liu Sheng says is infinity a useful
abstract concept that helps with
mathematical concepts only or is
infinity actually a reality in the
natural world can time for example be
infinite so we don't know I don't know
nobody else knows either
see absolutely no reason why Infiniti
couldn't be a reality in the natural
world in fact every single possible
theory of physics that we have actually
had success with since the time of Isaac
Newton uses the concept of infinity in a
very fundamental way even if it's just
saying that space is a continuum right
if you have quantum mechanics then this
space of all wave functions is a
continuum so there's an infinite number
of possible wave functions even in a
finite dimensional hilbert space there's
still an infinite number of vectors so I
don't see any problems with time being
infinite or space being infinite but of
course we don't have any evidence that
that's absolutely true
so I think it's safer to say we don't
know Raymond Abernethy says could you
explain what quantum error correction
entails I'm not sure how much detail you
want here so I'll try to give you know
the very basic idea there's something
called classical error correction which
is probably a good idea to understand
first and this is the idea let's say you
have a string of bits let's say you have
one bit okay so you have a bit that is
either 0 or 1 and you want to send it to
your friend but you send it over a wire
and there's noise on the wire and
there's always the possibility that the
bit just gets flipped there's some
probability that that happens just by
accident so how can you guard against
that classically what you can do is you
can duplicate that bit if it's a 0 or a
1 if it's 0 you turn that one 0 into 5
zeroes you send all 5 if it's a 1 you
turn into 5 ones and you send all 5 of
those and then when that your receiver
gets the message it is correspondingly
less likely that all of the bits have
flipped so you just do some majority
count and presume that that was the
message that you tried to send it's
never a hundred percent reliable but you
can increase the reliability as much as
you want there's a couple of problems
with that quantum mechanically one is
that it's you can't Xerox quantum
mechanical bits if someone gives you a
bit and says don't measure it just
duplicate it that is literally
impossible to do in quantum mechanics
there is a no-cloning theorem that says
you can't do that you can manipulate it
in different ways but you can't just
make many many copies of it and send all
those copies the other problem is when
you do measure a quantum
you only get to measure at once before
it disappears right because you've
destroyed it by by measuring it you've
changed its nature because its
wavefunction has collapsed so what you
end up doing is there's a way of taking
one bit and distributing the information
sort of basically what you're doing
you're diluting the bit
you're not xeroxing it many times but
you're diluting in this in the way that
if it's some linear combination of 0 & 1
you make a linear combination of 0 0 0 0
& 1 1 1 1 ok so you're distributing that
combination over many bits and then it
turns out the clever thing is you can
separately ask you can separately figure
out are all the bits that the receiver
receives the same or has one of them
flipped ok and if they're all receiving
the same one then you presume that ok it
probably came through okay and that's a
way that you can actually do quantum
error correction you can you can make
sure that it's very unlikely that you're
that all the bits were being flipped now
there is one interesting thing that is
worth mentioning here is that that kind
of process makes use of a hidden or
maybe not so hidden assumption which is
that if you have physical bits like
electron spins qubits quantum bits so
like electron spins or entanglement
between multiple particles or whatever
certain kinds of errors are more likely
than other kinds of errors it is more
likely to change one bit at a time by
that bit being hit by a cosmic ray or
whatever then all the all the bits
changing a little bit but in concert ok
so that's what makes quantum error
correction possible I hope that was some
help this is a absolutely very central
stuff for making practical quantum
computers Suraj Rajan says I just
finished the book and I've been real
istening to the last two chapters I
presume this is something deeply hidden
last two chapters over and over there's
so much jam-packed in there I'm still
struggling to understand what you mean
by degrees of freedom in chapter 14 is
this a stand-in or a euphemism for
something more fundamental well it's
it's both a stand-in in terms of
language so a degree of freedom is an
abstract kind of notion it could be
anything right if you have a single
particle moving through space then it's
three different location
three dimensions of space are all
degrees of freedom and it's three
momento in the three different
directions our degrees of freedom so we
talked about it having six degrees of
freedom a degree of freedom is just
something the system can do
independently of all other degrees of
freedom right so we say a particle has
six degrees of freedom because knowing
where it is in one dimension of space
doesn't tell you where it is in the
other two and likewise for the momentum
in quantum mechanics you have a lot of
degrees of freedom to take on the form
of qubits right or cute Ritz if it's
three different possible states etc so
rather than a continuous number like
location in space it is a quantum
mechanical qubit a superposition of zero
and one when we talk about in the
emergent space-time game when we talk
about a set of degrees of freedom
becoming entangled and giving rise to
space-time what we're doing is signaling
that we don't know what these bits are
what these qubits are these degrees of
freedom are or at least we're not
presuming to know I think that the
safest answer is there isn't anything
that they are they are the fundamental
stuff out of which the universe is made
you know there's some bottom layer and
the bottom you I thought about for the
book you know inventing a word for this
right inventing some nomenclature but
I'm no Marie goemon I'm not really as
good at this as he was so you know you
could call them pixels or atoms of
space-time or something like that but
none of those is really quite right
because they all evoke connotations I
don't want to evoke I mean in the real
correct theory of quantum gravity we
have very strong reason to believe that
the world is not made out of localized
degrees of freedom that the Greece of
freedom are somehow spread out over what
you and I would call positions in space
and so it's very tricky to get exactly
the right word so I just called them
degrees of freedom because they're the
things out of which this emergent
space-time is made Sandro Stuckey says
my question is about when macroscopic
Skol macroscopic objects cause
decoherence how can a quantum system
like a photon or an electron remain in a
coherent superposition while interacting
with a macroscopic object such as a beam
splitter or a screen with a double slit
but
not when interacting with the
measurement apparatus an observer or an
environment yeah I mean this is a good
and important question because and the
answer is there is a difference between
interacting with something and becoming
entangled with something so let's say
that you have an electron that is in a
superposition of spin up and spin down
okay and you bounce it off of a wall
don't ask me why Vectron is bounce but
maybe this one does okay the point is as
long as the spin up part of the electron
and the spin down part of the electron
bounce off the wall in exactly the same
way no entanglement happens in order for
entanglement to happen it's much more
it's not just that you interact is that
you interact differently for the
different parts of you that have gone
into the superposition so more
realistically an electron with spin up
or spin down will fall the same way in a
gravitational field so the electron does
not become entangled with the
gravitational field by doing that and so
in these idealization where you do
something like the double slit
experiment when you say the electron
goes through one slit or not the other
you're assuming that no matter what the
electron can interact with the slit by
being absorbed if it hits the somewhere
where there's you know something
blocking it and going through if it's
not but it interacts with such way that
it doesn't itself become entangled if it
did if the electron did become entangled
with the slits then you would not see
the interference pattern on the other
side George sharra pizza says George had
multiple questions so I picked one one
of the questions was in your work
dark matter with time dependent mass
that's a paper I wrote a while back a
while back over 20 years ago with Greg
Anderson you state that as the universe
expands the density of particles
decreases does that mean that along with
density the volume of the particles are
affected too and consequently the wave
function and clock of the particles so
this is an idea that Greg and I had a
long time back before we discover the
universe is accelerating this is sort of
a an early complicated theory of dark
energy before we knew we had evidence
that there was dark energy but imagine
that you
you have particles massive particles
which ordinarily we would say something
like the following as space expands and
volume goes up the number of particles
stays the same so the mass density of
particles goes down as one over the
volume in other words if you have a
scale factor which tells you the linear
size by which space is expanding the
volume goes as a cubed if a is the scale
factor and so the density goes is eight
to the minus three but that's assuming
that the mass of each particle and
therefore the energy of each particle is
constant we came up with a theory where
the mass of each particle increases with
time and it's not just by hand there's
other fields that are interacting with
it giving it a mass and so forth
after all this is exactly what does
happen at the electroweak phase
transition in the early universe when
the electron goes from having zero mass
to the mass it really has right so we
imagine that happens with dark matter
particles in the current universe and
it's consistently ongoing so all of this
was very classical you know it's just
there's some fields that are coupled to
each other we solve their equations of
motion so you're asking is the volume of
particles affected and the wave function
and the clock none of these things are
anything that we talked about you could
talk about them if you wanted to the
mass of the particles increases so the
Compton wavelength decreases in quantum
mechanics there's something called the
quanta the Compton wavelength which is
shorter for higher mass particles and
this is part of the fact that higher
mass is higher energy is shorter
distance I'm not sure what the clock of
the particles really means you know an
individual particle all by itself isn't
a very good clock it's not doing
anything it's not changing over time but
definitely the Compton wavelengths of
the particles would be decreasing that
is true Dimitra Tenko says the money
will con famously believe that space and
time as we know them are a priori
notions in our minds that allow us to
perceive the world a posteriori
according to Khan strands and mental
idealism we don't have access to the
nature of space and time and we can't
possibly know empirically whether they
actually exist 200 years later do we
have reasons to believe we will get to
know what space and time really are well
I you know my personal belief
that Kant was just totally wrong about
this I mean Convery famously and as we
will talk about briefly in an upcoming
podcast had an idea of the synthetic a
priori that there was something that
could be a priori true but was not true
just by the by the consequence of the
definitions of the terms in the
statement and so I don't actually agree
that there are such things as synthetic
a priori
I also don't agree separately that
there's anything really aa priori in our
minds about space and time I think it's
a failure of imagination to think that
we need space and time to perceive the
world I think that we have space in time
and we use them to perceive the world
but I'm open to the possibility that if
space and time were very different than
what we know them to be there would
still be something that we could imagine
calling perceiving the world so I and I
also think that it as a as a matter of
how science gets done you know this idea
of perceiving things as they are is
never how science gets done and by the
20th century we are very familiar with
our work from cosmology and relativity
and quantum mechanics and field theory
that our theories that we construct to
explain the world are very very distant
from our everyday experiences of the
world and the reason that we're able to
construct them is because we go back and
forth between theory and experiment and
ask what kinds of theoretical
predictions match the data etc so it's
not about you know perceiving directly
the reality it's about figuring out the
reality by the basis of this back and
forth scientific method and I see no
reason whatsoever to think that our
scientific method will not succeed at
telling us what space and time really
are that's my optimistic take Peter
Gerdes who goes by true path says I
often hear discussions about the arrow
of time talking about the need to
explain the fact that there was low
entropy in the early universe however
entropy is only defined relative to a
choice of macroscopic observables has
there been any work that tries to
consider what fraction of the possible
initial conditions would result in a low
entropy state relative to some notion of
macroscopic observables creatures in
that world might have so I'm not exactly
sure once again what you're what are you
looking for if what you're asking is
could you know is it
how easy is it or difficult or possible
is it to define entropy using a
different coarse graining right a
different choice of macroscopic
observables so that essentially any
configuration microscopically of the
system could by that novel coarse
graining count as low entropy
the answer is it's always possible to do
that absolutely you can ex post facto
post hoc come up with some something
that to us looks incredibly weird and
nevertheless has the feature that what
to you and I looks like thermal
equilibrium to this weird coarse
graining looks like a really low entropy
state where the entropy then starts to
increase
but it's not completely arbitrary how we
choose these course screenings not all
coarse graining x' are created equal
i think that carlo rovelli actually is
someone who's worked on an approach like
this and here's why i find it completely
unrealistic because i can look at some
box of gas that is in thermal
equilibrium from my point of view and i
say yes that is high entropy the gas is
all spread out and someone else says yes
but in the specific microstate that this
box of gas is in you know this atom is
here that atoms over there and here all
the for every single atom I'm gonna tell
you exactly the position momentum and
then I'm gonna coarse-grain in a weird
way so that makes that particular
configuration of position momentum low
entropy that's fine but it's completely
useless
there aren't any observers in principle
that observe the thing that way because
we know how observations work
observations work by looking at it right
there aren't enough photons leaving the
atoms in the gas for you to see that
very specific macro state that you're
talking about there are actual physical
constraints on how we observe things
when you talk about how we decide on
what's a macroscopic observable it's not
arbitrary we use the actual accessible
features of physics to make those
choices about how to coarse-grain in to
macroscopic observables so when we say
the early universe had low entropy
relative to some coarse graining on
phase space it's the right course
reigning on phase space it's not
something we could have chosen otherwise
someone whose handle is SK log W and who
I cleverly did not say squad I
understand what you're referring to
there it's the formula on Boltzmann's
tombstone
in something deeply hidden among other
things you propose that what we perceive
as physical proximity is an emergent
phenomenon of entanglement experiments
have shown that once entangled particles
can be physically separated over large
distances and stay entangled how is it
how is that fact reconciled with the
idea that entanglement causes us to
perceive physical proximity so the short
answer is the thing that causes the
distance in space-time measure the
metric the emergent space-time itself is
in particular the entanglement between
vacuum degrees of freedom between
degrees of freedom that are not
particles ok the degrees of freedom that
all that they're doing is making up
empty space so yes you can certainly
take two particles and entangle them
however you want and move them as far
away from each other as you want but it
is a fact about quantum field theory
that even if you have a very good cut
off on your quantum field theory so
there's not an infinite number of
degrees of freedom it is still true that
the overwhelming number of degrees of
freedom are just sitting there in their
vacuum state those are the degrees of
freedom that we use to define distance
they have nothing to do with actual
particles by definition of particles not
in this vacuum state the vacuum state
has no particles in it ok so that's the
short answer there is a longer answer
that I'm not going to give but I will
mention where to look to where to read
about it there's something called the ER
equals EPR conjecture by one model sane
and Lenny Susskind and they say that if
you have two entangled particles they're
secretly is a wormhole between them so
they're secretly is a very short
distance between them but as long as
they're just two particles not all the
particle the degrees of freedom around
them that's not going to define what you
macroscopically would perceive as the
space-time metric
mikail core bucco Kuroko core OpCo sorry
says Wojtek zurich in his existential
interpretation of quantum mechanics
argues that although the universe as a
whole is a quantum wave function once we
select one classical world as our
observed branch there's no reason to
treat other branches as equally real in
fact there is only this branch
the rest of the universe is simply in
the mixed quantum state such argument
seems to avoid some philosophical
problems of many worlds where multiple
persons exist in different branches
while I understand that branching is in
principle a matter of convenience why do
you treat other branches as equally real
so I think there's a couple reasons one
is you know the if you want to argue
well I don't need to treat the rest of
the wavefunction the universe as real I
would say why what is your reason not
for treating it as real right like I
don't need to treat the other side of
Los Angeles as real you know it just
exists in my mind maybe it becomes real
when I go visit but I don't need to
treat it as real but obviously it's just
way easier to treat it as real it's just
a simpler explanation for what's going
on in reality if I write down a wave
function where a priori there's a bunch
of pieces of it and they all look
equally real and then someone puts their
finger on one of the terms in the
wavefunction says yes but that's where I
live I don't see why suddenly all the
rest of the wave function becomes less
important and less real right and in
fact the argument about the probability
and the born rule goes the other way you
need multiple persons in other branches
to understand where probability comes
from Zurich has an argument for
probability but I think he's cheating
basically zero X argument for
probability comes down to the fact that
mathematically the wave function squared
is the only sensible thing that you
could apply to probability in many
worlds and that's certainly true but
that's kind of obviously trivially true
everyone's always known that everyone
always knew that if you got a
probability rule out of many worlds it
would be the wave function squared
that's not the surprise the important
question is why is there anything worthy
of the term probability at all and I
think in my personal view is that in
order to answer that question
you need to take the other worlds
seriously because I think that the
probability is a credence you put on the
self locating uncertainty attached to
all those different observers and all
those different branches Anders says
William Lane Craig insists that there is
an absolute reference frame from God's
view does this break anything in special
and general relativity or is it just an
unnecessary assumption
I don't think it necessarily breaks
anything in special relativity if it has
no effect on anything observable right
so it it it's much like good old Lorentz
Ian physics you know if you were a
physicists in the year 1900 you might
have believed in Lorentz Ian's mechanics
which was this idea that there was an
ether that fixed a rest frame for the
universe but it was just unobservable
because of the Lorentz transformations
if you want to believe that yeah I mean
go nuts it doesn't doesn't change
anything observable about the universe
it just makes your theory more
complicated so as a scientist I'm not
really interested in going down that
direction Dan inch says in the
many-worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics certain events can cause the
University of split and branch off could
anything make the worlds rejoin so that
their futures are realigned so yeah the
answer is it's possible for that to
happen it's just incredibly incredibly
unlikely like many things in the
multiverse in the many worlds of
wavefunction it is kind of like cream
and coffee spontaneously unmixing in a
cup of coffee but even way way way less
likely than that so it's one of these
things that is conceivable but doesn't
really keep me up at night
Clive Thompson says assume two
absolutely identical universes spring
into existence at exactly the same
moment identical except for one fluke
difference biology emerges in universe a
some eight billion light years into the
picture and continues for at least
billions of years which universe
experiences heat death first this
biology [ __ ] or accelerate entropy
I think the biology accelerates the rate
at which entropy is increasing biology
depends on the fact that there is low
entropy around that there is free energy
to be taken advantage of and biology
takes advantage of it by converting it
into higher entropy energy by getting
rid of the free energy and turning into
waste heat and so forth so just at a
qualitative level biology would
certainly increase the rate of entropy
production now realistically it's a tiny
fraction right I mean the Sun is doing a
way better job but increasing the
entropy of the universe then the earth
and the black hole at the center of our
galaxy is doing a way way way better job
at increasing the entropy of the
universe than all of the stars in the
Milky Way
so life does not play a very crucial
role in our actually universe but in
principle it speeds up the approach
towards heat death djw says why isn't
the second law of thermodynamics
considered to be a if not the solution
to the first law considered here on the
scale of the universe ie the big picture
so I'm not sure what to say because I'm
not sure exactly you mean by the phrase
the solution to the first law the first
law of thermodynamics says energy is
conserved it does not involve the word
entropy in any way the second law says
that entropy only increases or stays
constant in closed systems there's other
versions of it but that's the basic idea
I think that these are two independent
statements I can imagine worlds in which
energy is not conserved but the second
law is still true I can imagine worlds
in which the first law is true energy
still conserved but the second law is
not true for example a world in thermal
equilibrium or a world with just like
one simple harmonic oscillator rocking
back and forth where the entropy is just
not defined but energy is still
conserved so I really think that these
are separate things that work together
to give us the world of thermodynamics
that we actually observe gary Rancourt
says why is Fermi's beta decay paper
regarded as one of the greatest
contributions for 20th century physics I
think that there's I don't know I'm not
sure what the list of the greatest
contributions in twentieth-century
physics is it wouldn't be in the top
three right it wasn't the invention of
quantum mechanics and general relativity
or the expanding universe or something
like that but it's a great paper a great
advance most obviously because it
explains beta decay beta decay for those
of you out there who aren't familiar
it's just the decay via the weak
interactions and typically at high
energy electron is given off so a
neutron decaying into a proton electron
and antineutrino is an example of beta
decay a muon can decay into an electron
and two neutrinos same kind of thing and
so that's that's an important thing that
happens in the world and Fermi described
it correctly and so that's pretty good
right there like when you're the first
person to correctly describe a physical
thing that happens in fundamental
physics you win that's an important
contribution there is something else
over and above
which is that Fermi's theory might
arguably be the first successful
application of quantum field theory to
the matter side of the ledger I mean you
know if you think about it we had
classical field theory with
electromagnetism and therefore it made
perfect sense that when people started
trying to understand quantum field
theory they first started with
electromagnetism right with the forces
side of the ledger the electric field in
the magnetic field and matter was
thought of as particles you know and and
the fact that you could think of matter
as fields was less obvious and one of
the reasons why quantum field theory is
important for what we think of as
particles what we think of as matter is
because you see particles changing into
each other you see one kind of particle
like a neutron changing into another one
like a proton without field theory
that's very very difficult to describe
in fact there's more or less a folk
theorem that says if you want special
relativity and particles changing their
identities then you need quantum field
theory or something like it and Fermi's
but beta decay paper was one of the
first that used quantum field theory to
describe the transformation of one kind
of particle into another Ian Morgan says
well how about doing a sort of runners
and riders thing where you discussed the
main theories being put forward for the
unification of quantum and classical
physics I'm a little confused about the
status of string theory it's been
knocking around for at least 30 years
now and although many physicists are
working away like crazy at it there does
not seem to be any prospect of it ever
replacing or being added to the existing
model I don't know yeah I don't know
that's not that's not really something
that is a very exciting thing for me to
imagine doing to be honest I don't think
I have much to add or to say about it
you know string theory is still by a
very large distance the leading approach
to reconciling quantum mechanics with
gravity I think it's so leading that
there aren't any other approaches that
are a close second right there's
basically string theory and then a bunch
of stragglers that is not to say string
theory is right one of the stragglers
could be right or some idea that no one
has yet put forward could be right but
it's not really a fair fight in terms of
the intellectual attention being paid to
the
at different theories and there's good
reasons for that you may or may not
agree with the reasons but there are
reasons about the fact that string
theory seems to predict things very
naturally that other theories really
struggle to get right so rather than
like rating them some you know poll like
you know a new poll for the football
teams or something like that college
football polls I would just need like to
talk individually about the prospects of
the different possibilities I thought
about my own ideas from I've talked
about my own ideas of emergent
space-time from the quantum wave
function we've talked with Carlo Rovelli
about loop quantum gravity we've talked
to string theorists so I think they do
you know there's a temptation to think
you know something is right we should
figure out what it is right away and
work on that that's just not how science
works you have to keep many balls being
juggled in the air until you figure out
which is right and that doesn't bother
me that we don't yet know which of the
many theories is right let them all be
studied and hopefully some breakthroughs
will happen and we'll make progress
Charlie Morris says can you give some
insight on free will I'm an engineer and
I live in Newtonian clockwork universe I
think the direction that an electron
flows is only physics could you comment
I agree that the direction of an
electron flows is only physics no one I
don't think anyone should be attributing
freewill to electrons I'm not going to
give a long answer here because I've
written about this at length you can
find online my blog post called free
will is as realized baseball and even
better because I thought about it a lot
more since then you could read my book
the big picture where I talk about free
will or on the podcast you could listen
to my discussions with Daniel Dennett or
Jenn an SPL where we talk about these
things in some detail especially Jenn an
wrote a whole book how physics makes us
free the very very short answer is that
we're not electrons an electron is
something I can completely describe I
can create it in a state where I know
everything it's doing a person is not
person is made of a lot of particles and
the best I can do is approximate them an
emergent higher level description and
part of that emergent higher level
description is oh this person makes
choices and does things and thinks it
has reasons
for the choices they make and just
talking that vocabulary automatically
puts you in a position where you're
talking about freewill freewill is a
convenient way of talking about
macroscopic human scale actions in the
psychological world Jack Parkin says
during your conversation with Kevin Han
you guys talked excitedly about Gibbs
free energy will you be willing to talk
a little more about its importance to
life so yeah without going into
equations you know the Gibbs free energy
is comes from the idea that if you have
some thermodynamic system let's say you
have a box of gas but rather than all
the gas being spread through the box
there's a piston in the box right so the
gas is being compressed so it's on half
the side of the box and the other half
of the side is just empty it's just
vacuum okay so there's a certain amount
of energy there and you can imagine
slowly pulling the piston out so that
you know no energy is exchanged we call
this an adiabatic transformation and so
that at the end the piston is extended
all the way to the end of the box and so
now the gas is completely full to the
everywhere in the box and now it's at
its maximum entropy State so if you did
this very very slowly you wouldn't
actually change the total amount of
energy in the box but you would have
increased the entropy inside the box and
before you did that there was some
energy that you could have extracted you
could have rather than gently pulling
the piston out you could have let the
pressure of the gas push the piston this
is actually what happens in your car
unless you own an electric vehicle you
explode a gas inside a piston it creates
a lot of pressure and it pushes on the
piston okay so for a system that is not
in thermal equilibrium a system that is
not at its highest energy state there's
a certain amount of energy it has and
there's some subset of that energy which
is available to do useful work that
subset of the energy that is useful is
the free energy it's free energy not in
the sense that it's freely available but
that it is free to do something it's
more like freedom of speech than free
beer okay it's free to do useful work
like pushing a piston or something like
that
so to say that a system has a lot of
free energy is to say that it has low
entropy those are basically the same
thing there's some details once again
that's basically the same idea and what
that means is the entropy wants to
increase the free energy wants to
dissipate and be converted into heat and
that want that teleological
or anthropocentric language is a way of
making life possible right because life
relies on all this energy to do things
if you're already in thermal equilibrium
you don't have any energy to do anything
might have a lot of energy but it's all
useless energy so you can't power
thinking and metabolism and all that
stuff that is important to life so a big
part of the understanding the origin of
life is understanding what free energy
there was in the environments of these
worlds and why and how chemistry
organized itself in such a way to
release that free energy via the
creation of living organisms
Spencer Hargis says do you think that
many worlds either in a quantum sense or
infinite universe tends have any
implications for understanding of
history for example the Cuban Missile
Crisis I think no no not not useful
implications for again the same reasons
that I gave before maybe not completely
clearly but I think that you know having
thought about it's not at all obvious
but I think if you think about it
carefully the conclusion you reach is
that the way you should treat decisions
and history and morality and
consequences of your actions in and
ever-ready in multiverse is exactly the
same as how you should treat them in a
truly stochastic universe where things
happen but with the probability given by
the born rule so I don't think that in
terms because your decisions don't
create universes universes are created
by quantum decoherence events and your
decisions might be affected by those but
that's the way the arrow of causality
flows and for the cosmological
multiverse where there's things very
very far away you know there's no
influence directly on anything you do
that's happening over there so you know
the fact that the universe is big in one
sense or another and therefore that many
things happen doesn't affect history or
morality or ethics in any interesting
way as far as I can tell now it would be
different
if literally everything happened with an
equal probability right that would make
for a very boring world in some sense it
would be a world where in some sense
there's no consequence to anything
because literally everything happens and
everything that happens counts equally
well right but that's not there's no
evidence for that in either quantum
mechanics or cosmology the worlds don't
count equally some worlds are more
likely some worlds count more than
others and so that matters so I think
that history is more or less history as
we think about it
George Faulkner says the recent New York
Times obituary Oh mathematician john
conway referred to the free will theorem
and it's connection to the coca
inspector theorem related to quantum
mechanics as a naturalist I don't accept
contra causal free will and that humans
or other creatures have such so I wonder
if you can explain what it is meant by
this use here or if maybe Conway etc
should have used different terminology
that's less loaded with freewill baggage
yeah so let me be very clear there is a
theorem by Conway and Conway and cockin
was it that they called the free will
theorem and this theorem has absolutely
zero nothing but cos to do with free
will in any way at all
it's just good marketing ok can't be
more clear about this I'm trying to be
as clear as I can nothing to do with
free will what the theorem has to do
with it's one in a long line of theorems
in quantum mechanics about indeterminacy
much like Bell's Theorem and other
theorems along those lines it says given
these assumptions that seem to make
sense to us certain things are
unpredictable ok and so for fun or for
marketing purposes they translated
certain things are unpredictable into
it's like electrons have free will it's
really not at all like electrons have
free will and just to be more clear
about that there is no correlation
whatsoever
between whether or not the universe is
deterministic versus stochastic and
whether or not you believe in free will
or not the only implication of the free
will theorem has to do with whether you
believe the universe is deterministic or
stochastic therefore is nothing what's
ever to do with free will you can be
determinist and believe in free will or
not believe in free will
you can believe the universe is
stochastic and believe in free will or
not believe in free will if your
interest is in Contra causal free will
then what matters is not whether the
laws of physics are deterministic or
stochastic what matters is just that
there are laws and if your interest is
in compatibilist free will then the fact
that the laws of physics are
deterministic or stochastic again
doesn't matter the slightest bit so it
just is a label that you know worked
they it did its job you would never have
heard of that theorem if they had called
it the indeterminism theorem but it has
nothing to do with freewill
Fadi Yunus says considering that the
chances of the LHC finding evidence for
supersymmetry are now pretty low and the
prospects of building a bigger particle
collider are slim
what are your pressing credence is for
string theory being the theory of
everything and what track do you think
physics should follow in pursuit of the
theory of everything so I think it's
fair to say that that well so it's hard
to say that the prospects are finding
supersymmetry the LHC are pretty low it
that might be true but that depends on
you know your priors for various
different things so let me just mention
that that's not a completely
unproblematic statement certainly it's
true that the chances of finding
supersymmetry the LHC are lower now than
they were 10 years ago before we turn
the LHC on because we could have found
it during the last 10 years
so whatever credence you had on theories
that have supersymmetry in them should
be lower now than they were 10 years ago
that's perfectly fair by how much lower
they should be is the hard question of
course now string theory does require
supersymmetry for it to work but string
theory doesn't require supersymmetry at
the electroweak scale necessarily the
fact that supersymmetry is broken near
the electroweak scale and therefore is
observable at the LHC was always
motivated by things like the hierarchy
problem the mass of the Higgs boson is
very different than the Planck scale etc
nothing directly to do with string
theory whatsoever still like I said the
string theory relies on supersymmetry
and it could have been there so it would
have been fair had we found
supersymmetry the LHC
for your prior to go up for string
theory and it's likewise fair for your
prior to go down for string theory now
that we haven't found it but by how much
is gonna depend on whether or not you
thought it was really likely to begin
with and also what your alternatives to
string theory that you're considering
and your set of priors really is so I do
take seriously the fact that both the
LHC is not found new particles and the
fact that we've not found weakly
interacting massive particles in Dark
Matter detectors either as evidence that
it's it's at least plausible that the
electroweak scale has far fewer
particles than we thought and that is
surprising to me and puzzling because
there are puzzles with the electroweak
scale the hierarchy problem and related
puzzles the dark matter problem etc so I
am certainly motivated to look for more
dramatic departures from the
conventional wisdom violations of
quantum field theory and Lorentz
invariance and you know things like that
so therefore that is what I am doing but
you know it's definitely high risk high
gain kind of pursuit you know I can't
say this and I've said this many times
I'll say it again
string theory did not become popular
because people said well we need to
quantize gravity what's the best way we
have of doing it no one was trying to
quantize gravity people invented string
theory try to understand the strong
interactions back in the 1960s and 70s
gravity came out as a bonus and then
later it was shown that the theory is
finite there's no none of these
infinities that we need to worry about
early on so this is why ed Witten said
that string theory use a piece of 21st
century physics that fell into the 20th
century it's sort of string theory is
much better than what we were trying to
do with it and this is something that
researchers in string theory will tell
you over and over again that the theory
seems smarter than the theorists it
seems to be giving us surprises that
work really nicely that doesn't mean is
right you know it could still be wrong
but the kinds of alternatives that are
being pursued including by myself don't
yet have that flavor that
the theory is smarter than us the theory
is hard you know like like I said in my
most recent paper with Charles Thao
about emergent space-time our strategy
was to be very honest and write down a
set of assumptions that give us the
answer that we want to get and you could
equally well call our set of assumptions
a wish list these are the things that we
hope are true but haven't yet proven are
true and they are all obstacles they're
all things that until we prove that
they're true we can't be convinced that
this is on the right track and but again
that's okay you know there's no reason
to think the quantizing gravity should
be easy people should try lots of
different things you know if I that's my
sort of pro string theory pitch in some
sense my anti string theory pitch is
that I do think that there are there's a
segment of the string theory community
that has become enamored with doing
string theory
at the cost of doing physics in other
words they answer questions that are
stated within the paradigm of string
theory and lose track of the fact that
the ultimate goal is to make contact
with experiments I'm not bothered by the
fact that string theory hasn't yet made
contact with experiments it's hard it's
a theory of gravity in the Planck scale
is well beyond the reach of our particle
accelerators but I still think we need
to try if you if you want to say well
it's just too hard then maybe you should
work something on something else that is
not a theory of quantum gravity right if
you say well it's hard but I think it's
still worth working on this theory then
you really need to keep your eyes on the
prize and keep trying to connect it to
experiments Stephan darling house says
in 1977 the Voyager Golden Record took
diverse poor trails of diversity of life
on earth and culture to outer space
together with instructions on how the
record is supposed to be understood by
any life out there lucky enough to pick
it up
imagine the Human Genome Project was
already completed back in 1977 I wonder
whether it might have been a good idea
to put the information on human DNA onto
the record thus sending the possibility
to outer space that humans might be
reproduced and in some way may live far
away in both time and space on alien
worlds slim as the chance of that maybe
I don't know that's a really cool
thought experiment honestly
you know I was always skeptical that the
golden record on Voyager even if it was
eventually you know 15 million years
from now picked up by some super
intelligent alien civilization would
have been decodable and understandable
at anyways like I don't know if I could
decode it and understand it and I'm a
human being but I get the you know the
the thought experiment is should we send
out our genome into space you know I
think that I'm in the minority here I'm
on the side of being a little bit
careful when it comes to talking to
aliens if there's no aliens out there no
technologically advanced civilizations
it doesn't matter you know knock
yourself out
so the presumably you're assuming that
this will actually be found by aliens
and I think that it's logical to assume
the average technological civilization
out there in the Milky Way is of order a
billion years more advanced than us and
so we are to them as I don't know
certainly much tinier than a mosquito
maybe like a bacterium to them right in
terms of advancement so we're nothing to
them they could destroy us and maybe not
even care not even notice it's like
spring a can of Lysol to us would be
wiping out the earth to them maybe maybe
not
okay we don't know but it's at least
perfectly plausible so given how young
and juvenile and it formed an
ill-prepared we are I'm not really
interested in calling attention to us
and especially giving away the secrets
of our genome etc that's probably not
what I would consider to be a good
strategy better safe than sorry when it
comes to talking to the aliens I will
say Paulina Barron says is there a
question you would like to answer which
has never been asked I would love to
hear about it
ah so you I thought about this I read
this question Polina and I thought about
it and I'm just not gonna give you a
good answer yes the real truth here is
that between having a blog for many
years and tweeting and having a podcast
and doing videos and doing ask me
anything and writing books and writing
articles and giving talks I think that
there's a much higher number of things
that I've said and didn't need to say
then there are things that I really
wanted to say and have it had a chance
the things I wanted to say I have had
chance now the there's a footnote there
there are things I want to write books
don't want to write papers I want to
write that I haven't yet written that I
that I have thought of the idea for them
but haven't yet written and so those
would be what I should tell you as part
of the answer but I don't want to tell
you those because I don't want to I
don't like giving away too much about
projects that I'm working on that are
still in the process of going on because
they could change and people say you
know why did it change sometimes they
don't even come into existence some
people like yeah you wimped out you
didn't finish it and even if no one is
like that except me I'm still like that
so I don't like to be too public
about what I'm working on before it's
near completion the one exception to
that is I have signed a contract to
write a book an undergraduate textbook
on quantum mechanics so that I'm gonna
do but other but that's not the answer
to your question sorry about that if I
think of a better question that I would
like to answer there's never been asked
I'll try to talk about it next time we
do an AMA Alex Zhu Cominco says is there
a way to have a representation or
transformation when potential energy and
kinetic energy looks the same and more
words there if you want to look up the
question that Alice asked yes and no
this is one of those yes-or-no questions
depending on how you ask the question so
if you look into the video I did the
biggest ideas in the universe video I
did on force energy and action I talked
about the Hamiltonian did I talk about
in the Hamiltonian is that where I
talked about it one of these I don't
know space no actually I think you
talked about it mostly in the video on
space now that I'm thinking about it
anyway I talked about the Hamiltonian
formulation of classical mechanics and a
Hamiltonian formulation is one where the
way that you get the equations of
motions to find a function called the
Hamiltonian and it's a function of two
things the position and the momentum
okay so in ordinary Newtonian mechanics
how you learned it in school the thing
is you have a position that changes with
time and you derive from that position
changing with time the velocity and the
acceleration and so forth by taking
derivatives so it gets built into our
that velocity is derived from position
and momentum is derived from velocity
but in the Hamiltonian way of thinking
you don't you have to undo that thought
and this is very hard to undo thoughts
like that but you have to think of
momentum and position as truly
independent things and then you write
down a formula starting from position
and momentum for what the total energy
is so the simplest thing you can write
down for is the simple harmonic
oscillator where you have a kinetic
energy which is one-half P squared
divided by M divided by the mass and you
have a potential energy which is
one-half M x squared where X is the
position P is the momentum so those two
parts of the energy look the same or at
least they look equivalent right
they both is P squared for the kinetic
energy x squared for the potential
energy but that's just for that specific
example once you become more complicated
once you have two harmonic oscillators
or a field or a non harmonic oscillator
for that matter then the kinetic energy
and potential don't look the same
anymore and that's an interesting
question you know why do potential
energy and kinetic energy look so
different why it's it's related to the
question which I think to me is is the
fundamental one why our position and
momentum similar but different at the
same time given that they are similar
why are they different at all so they
are different does the short answer to
your question but it's an interesting
thing to wonder why they are so
different
Thomas Prunty says could you recommend
the technical reference for decoherence
as it relates to many worlds it's not
something you typically see in quantum
mechanics textbook or classes so for the
many-worlds part of it David Wallace's
book is the classic book the emergent
multiverse that's explicitly about the
many-worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics and there are very few books
that are explicitly about that so
probably that's what you want but
there's also you can still think about
decoherence whether or not you're
committed to many worlds and for that
there's a wonderful book by maximilian
schloss our called decoherence bla bla
bla I don't forget the subtitle but it's
a technical reference and it's
all about decoherence and how it appears
in many circumstances you should check
that out floss our Gerald Ruben says I
wonder if I was a scientist but I were
as as small as an atom the question is
could I detect the Sun I do not think I
can see it with those bright little eyes
so Gerard I think that you're assuming
some things that are hard to
consistently assume here so I mean I
know you're asking what if a person was
as tiny as an atom what if you were
ant-man and you were in the quantum
realm okay so I don't want to disabuse
anybody but ant-man is not really
realistic you really can't do that and
it's not just that we don't know where
it's hard or whatever it's really the
fundamental laws of nature that get in
your way so the problem is that when you
try to make things really really small
in quantum mechanics the wavelength of
the thing has to be get smaller and
smaller and smaller and we've already
mentioned once in this AMA the concept
of the Compton wavelength of a particle
and the thing about the Compton
wavelength is as the Compton wavelength
gets smaller the mass of the particle
gets larger so in the classical world
like where there's people and planets
and so forth these are objects that have
Compton wavelengths but the Compton
wavelengths are incredibly tiny your
Compton wavelength is much much smaller
than an atom okay way smaller so that's
why you look classical you look like a
point you look like something is moving
with a definite positioning velocity
through the world whereas when you're at
the level of individual atoms the
Compton wavelength is the size of the
thing the Compton wavelength of the
electron fixes the size of the atom and
the Compton wavelength of the nucleus is
smaller but you'll notice the nucleus is
much heavier so if you try to imagine
sub structure in an atom like bright
little eyes well what does that sub
structure made out of it needs to be
made out of things that are small
compared to the atom but anything that
is small compared to an atom is going to
be heavy compared to an atom so most of
the mass of the atom will be in that
tiny little thing that you just made
heavy particles like top quarks or Higgs
bosons can be very small but they're
also much heavier than atoms and they
decay away very very quickly so I'm just
trying to you know take your question at
face value is here
easily as possible in the real world the
reason why I thought experiment like
this doesn't work is you can't build
complicated things that are the size of
atoms but not much much heavier than
atoms that's the problem and therefore
you're not going to see the Sun in the
usual way because you won't have the
ability to absorb photons with your
eyeballs okay most atoms don't absorb
photons from the Sun in any in any
direct way they can be hit by a photon
and you can either bounce off or you can
either heat up the atom so the atom
stays in its its ordinary state as a
whole but it's moving left and right up
and down so it gets thermally excited
that's why you get hot on a hot day
outside if the photons from the Sun are
powerful enough they can actually change
the energy of the electrons in the atom
okay but none of that has anywhere near
the precision and the the depth of
information content to say oh look
there's a hot spot in a cold sky right
that's that was what would count to me
as detecting the Sun and so individual
atoms by themselves I would say don't
have the ability to detect the Sun in
the way that we usually think about it
gabor Peter ser says my questions about
black holes we know the generality is
not applicable at the singularity I'm
aware of the holographic principle
according to which the information
content is proportional to the surface
of the event horizon instead of the
volume of a black hole could you imagine
an experiment or observation that will
result in the loss of general
relativity's applicability not only the
singularity but at the event horizon of
a black hole so I can certainly imagine
that happening
it's harder to imagine detecting it
because if you're literally at the event
horizon then there's no coming out right
that's the point of no-return that's the
point it want once you're there you're
gonna go in you're not gonna come back
out but you could say if general
relativity was not completely true after
her at the horizon maybe it's also not
completely true 1% further out of the
black hole than the horizon just outside
the horizon in that case you
you can imagine observations what you
would want to do is try to figure out
what is the curvature of space-time what
is the space-time metric what is the
solution to Einstein's equation near the
event horizon of a black hole is it the
Kerr solution keer R that is what
general relativity predicts as the
unique solution to a spinning neutral
black hole in the real world that's what
we expect most black holes to be but
it's very specific there's only one
answer giving me the spin giving me the
mass I know what the metric is supposed
to be I know what the spacetime is
supposed to be doing so of course
looking for deviations from the curve
metric is a very high-priority thing
it's just hard it's hard to look that
close to the event horizon of a black
hole we're trying it I mean you know
that we had the event horizon telescope
that took a little picture of a black
hole but the picture was kind of fuzzy
it was a low resolution picture let's
put it that way
and not yet good enough to actually
detecting deviations from general
relativity but that's the kind of thing
we're hoping for Lisa Li si is a
proposed gravitational wave satellite in
space satellite in space of course a
gravitational wave observatory in space
that would be able to do the following
will be able to track medium sized black
holes you know the size of the Sun solar
mass black holes are ten solar mass
black holes as they spiral into
supermassive black holes as they spiral
into black holes that are a million or a
billion times the mass of the Sun and
that unlike the LIGO events which are
very quick and noisy these events with a
black hole spiraling into a supermassive
black hole take time and sort of
leisurely map out the curvature of space
near the event horizon of that
supermassive black hole so that is you
know probably the combination of most
feasible and most accurate map of what's
going on near the event horizon that we
can imagine in my lifetime anyway so I'm
hoping that happens I would you know I'm
not sure what percentage chance I would
put on general relativity being right or
wrong near the horizon certainly the
smart money is it's probably right but
if it were a little bit wrong that could
be really really really
important Gregory coos Nick says what is
your bacon number the Kevin Bacon
numbers of course I'm sure you all know
is the number of linkages between you
and Kevin Bacon when the linkage counts
as you and somebody else appearing in
the same movie so it depends on how you
count because two things one do TV shows
count actually three things one two TV
shows count to do appearances as
yourself versus as an actor count right
so if you count TV shows and you count
appearances as yourself then my bacon
number is three I've been in TV shows
with Morgan Freeman through the wormhole
with Morgan Freeman as well as with
Stephen Colbert The Colbert Report and
both Morgan Freeman and Stephen Colbert
have been in movies with people who have
been in movies with Kevin Bacon so there
you go my bacon number is three in that
sense if you actually want acting I
haven't done any acting so I can't
really do that if you want movies I
think it's still three but I'm not sure
I've never my face has never appeared in
a movie but my voice appeared in the
movie called earth to echo earth to echo
was a science fiction movie and they
played in the background of one of the
scenes a clip of me talking about
wormholes in time travel or something
like that so that's where I get my you
know one dollar every six months
residual check from the Screen Actors
Guild very very lucrative job fiat owner
says when I read Stephen Weinberg's the
first three minutes how should I think
about those three minutes my
understanding is that gravity affects
time so is there something special given
the extraordinary conditions that
prevailed then so I kind of answered
this before but the short answer is no
time dilation is not something that
actually happens just because there's a
lot of matter around you it happens
because there's a differential
gravitational field like the
gravitational field is different if
you're close to a black hole or even on
the surface of the earth than if you are
in empty space but if the whole universe
is smoothly pervaded with matter time
just clicks on one second per second
like it should Doug el taupe says what a
theory of quantum gravity be equivalent
to a theory of quantum space-time you
know I think basically the answer is yes
the only reason I say basically is
there's a
little bit of a subtlety space-time is a
classical notion space-time exists as a
classical thing in general relativity or
even a Newtonian space-time for that
matter so it's not clear that the
correct theory of quantum gravity is one
that starts with space-time and then
quantized is it so space-time might be
an approximation that emerges out of the
correct theory of quantum gravity or it
might turn out that space-time is part
of the ingredients of a theory of
quantum gravity and we actually don't
know which one is correct because we
don't know what the right theory quantum
gravity is as yet John Brady says
without asking you do a lot of research
and since the project only officially
started on April 14th just curious as to
whether you have any first impressions
of the wolfram physics project so I
think I've already given those first
impressions above like I said good for
him I don't see I'm not being given
nearly enough evidence to pay close
attention to it myself
James kaduk says I'm fascinated by the
idea that according to our current
understanding of the expansion of the
universe there will come a time when
sentient observers in the merged Milky
Way and dromeda galaxies won't be able
to see anything in the universe beyond
their galaxy and the CMB will have
cooled beyond the tech Tbilisi would
those observers have any hope of
deducing the history of the universe as
we understand it today
any hope yeah I mean they have some hope
it's a it'll be much harder right
science is always hard you know
scientists have to work with the data
we're given you know thinking about the
history of life on Earth as this
property like so this is not you know
the the idea that well someday the local
group will emerge in one big galaxy and
all the other galaxies have gone
therefore we can't do cosmology anymore
is too strong we are very interested in
knowing how life began here on earth
that's difficult because the life that
first started is not the life that's
around today there is the equivalent of
an event horizon between us but that
doesn't mean we don't try that doesn't
mean we don't try to use our brains and
our experimental results to try to
figure out how life if could have
evolved and then use that those sets of
hypotheses to compare them to how it did
evolve and see what the most likely
prospects are so I think that
the it's better safer more realistic to
say that is the cosmic microwave
background fades and other galaxies go
away cosmology becomes harder and harder
it never becomes impossible there's
never a hard bright line we should never
think of the way we do things now is the
only way that things can get done Jonas
says special relativity is the formalism
that makes the equations describing the
world look the same for all observers
moving with constant speed with respect
to each other is it correct to interpret
general relativity the same way ie is
the formalism that makes the equations
describing the world look the same for
all accelerated observers or is it
something more than that assumed needed
to be assumed in order in general
relativity in order to get gravity so
there's a few things going on here one
is general relativity has nothing to do
with acceleration okay there's no reason
not to include acceleration in special
relativity indeed the most famous
thought experiment special relativity is
the twin paradox and the twin paradox
involves a twin that is accelerated in
their rocket ship and that's kind of
crucially important so acceleration and
general relativity are completely
destroying questions you can have
accelerated motion or on accelerated
motion in either special relativity or
general relativity the difference
between accel general relativity and
special relativity is that in special
relativity space-time is fixed and flat
and non dynamical and there is no
gravity in general relativity space time
is dynamical it warps and changes and
gets curved in response to matter and
energy and we interpret that change in
the warping as as gravity so it is
certainly not true that the equations
describing the world look the same for
all accelerated observers I'm not even
sure what that means of course the
equations describing the world can
always look the same to all observers
they're the laws of physics right
Einstein's equation looks the same to
all observers the geodesic equation
looks the same to all observers but
unlike inertial observers there is no
equivalence between accelerated
observers you might talk about this and
again I'm gonna forget which one but in
one of the biggest ideas in the universe
videos
the point of relativity is there is no
preferred location in space there's no
preferred velocity through space there
is a preferred acceleration namely zero
we can tell whether we are accelerated
we can not tell where we are if we're in
a box that is opaque we cannot tell how
fast we're moving but we can tell
whether we're accelerated and that is a
hundred percent equally true in
generality or special relativity what
you need to assume in general relativity
to get gravity is you need to allow
space-time to be curved that's what you
need tgd says when people refer to time
passing more slowly close to a large
gravitational mass I've already talked
about that you know I don't blame you TG
because everyone talks about it that way
I've tried to explain why I don't like
to talk about it that way how much of
that is due to being accelerated through
curved space-time versus just being in a
just being in a curved space-time so
it's not due to being accelerated
through curved space-time at all so I
know what you mean when you're sitting
on the earth there's two things going on
one is you're in a gravitational
potential well right it would take you
energy to get from the surface of the
earth to infinity very far away and you
are not in free fall in that
gravitational field the earth is
preventing you from being in freefall so
you might want to know how would the
interval on a clock measure differently
if you were in freefall versus if you
weren't well the answer is it's
complicated you know both effects matter
and the point is you need to sort of
tell me what trajectory you're on in
freefall versus not in freefall so in
fact actually I'll be very honest about
this I made a boo-boo
I made the 1 actual you know obvious
scientific mistake in my very first book
from eternity to here was I got this
exactly wrong because I I talked about
the difference between an observer who
is just stationary on earth versus an
observer who is in orbit around the
earth 1 meter above the surface right
and they're in the same gravitational
field but one is moving and one is
on a geodesic if you're orbiting you're
on a do desig and one is not on a
geodesic but what I didn't take into
account was the special relativity
effect of course the geodesic is is has
a velocity and so you actually have to
do the calculation and as Don page
famous physicist who kindly emailed me
and pointed out that I've made a boo-boo
so that was got corrected in the updated
printings but you know in general
there's no easy answer to these
questions the answer is yet there are
competing effects you have to completely
specify how you're moving through
space-time and there's a formula for
calculating how much time elapsed along
your trajectory and since there are
competing effects you can't simplify it
beyond that
Gordon bambor says my question is about
angular momentum spinning stars can
collapse into millisecond neutron stars
which are amazing objects but how about
if the collapse continues toward a black
hole before the singularity is reached
can the spin increase to the point where
the equator moves at the speed of light
I think you're gonna be able to guess
the answer to this question no nothing
can move at the speed of light or faster
than the speed of light if it's not a
photon or another massless particle now
of course you have to be careful what do
you mean the speed of light relative to
what right if you're not moving at the
speed of light and there's always a rest
frame in which your velocity is zero so
again there's sort of a simple answer
and the complicated answer there's an
angular momentum that you can possibly
have and there is an upper limit on the
angular momentum just from the fact that
you begin to fly apart if your angular
momentum is too great but unsurprisingly
if gravity is pulling you together to
make a black hole you never reach that
point the force of gravity just pulls
you in long before you would get there
the interesting thing is that even after
you're a black hole you can still be a
spinning black hole I mean that's that's
kind of one of these things where it
sounds obvious of course black holes can
spin until you learn a little bit and
you learn that a black hole is not an
object black hole is a region of
space-time it's a region of space-time
with the property that once you go in
you can't come out again and then you
begin to ask questions like you know
what does it mean for a region of
space-time to be spinning and you can
define it you can define it in terms of
you know there's if you if you think
about
the rest frames that are near the
surface of a black hole to an observer
far away they would seem to be orbiting
around the black hole so you can
actually define physically what it means
and it all makes perfect sense and
angular momentum is conserved and
everyone's happy nothing is moving
faster than the speed of light
maxime aleksandrovitch says according to
the many-worlds interpretation every
time we choose Diet Coke over regular
coke the wavefunction collapses and
since creating a hole perfectly balanced
universe caused zero energy we were
responsible for creating a lot of other
universes as far as I understand moving
real consciousness between those worlds
would require some new type of force in
addition to the four we all know and
love so it's out of the question but
since we created a lot of other well
balanced universes populated with some
fake characters wouldn't they simply
carry on as psychological zombies in a
world without conscious observers
there's a again a few things going on
here one is let me say very clearly you
making decisions has nothing to do with
branching the wave function of the
universe if anything is the other way
around branching of the wave function of
the universe might affect you in such a
way that you think about it as a
decision being made but you do not
create new universes in fact I think
that it's a very very good approximation
to imagine that human decision-making is
pretty darn classical and even if you're
not sure whether you won the diet coke
or a regular coke that doesn't mean that
in 50% of the universes you're gonna get
one in 50% you're gonna get the other
it's probably in 99.999% you get one and
you just didn't know what that one was
ahead of time so it's the laws of
physics that make new universe is not
new human choice making so but the other
thing is I think that from the what I
read between the lines in your question
is the idea that you are attributing
somehow less consciousness to the copies
of you in other universes than the
copies of you in your universe and I
think that is not correct I think they
are all equally conscious there are no
zombies in any of these worlds that we
might take on it because I think the
consciousness is a purely physical thing
there's no essence of you that carries
on through some single trajectory
through the wave function of the
universe there's more and more people
who multiply and they're all equally
conscious
in ours says does the many-worlds
interpretation basically say that
everything happens and isn't that a bit
wasteful so no not everything happens
some things happen some things don't
there's an equation the many-worlds
interpretation says look here's an
equation it's called the Schrodinger
equation it says what happens whether
it's a bit wasteful is no it's not
wasteful at all so the point here the
reason why I can say that with such
conviction is the wave function the
quantum mechanical wave function is a
vector in this giant mathematical space
called Hilbert space and in the
many-worlds interpretation that vector
evolves according to the equation the
Schrodinger equation and that's all it
ever does if anything is going to be
wasteful it is the fact that hilbert
space is big so there might be many many
many many components to that wave
function but that's true in every
version of quantum mechanics if you have
any version of quantum mechanics that
has wave functions and has Hilbert space
the helper space is equally big in all
the versions of quantum mechanics
nothing bigger about it in many worlds
if you believe that I'm allowed in
quantum mechanics to think of an
electron being in a superposition of
spin up and spin down there's nothing
more wasteful than that to saying that
you should believe the universe can be
in a superposition in many different
states at once it doesn't cost anything
more and the equation the Schrodinger
equation says that we get there it is
not wasteful at all it is the leanest
meanest version of quantum mechanics
anyone has yet invented Paul cousin says
I'd really like to get some podcast
recommendations from you science or
anything else so I'm not gonna do a good
job at this because like popular science
books despite being a producer I'm not
that much of a consumer when it comes to
podcasts the one I always mention that I
really like is the Marc Maron show what
WTF this is I have to now nowadays I
have to classify my podcast episodes as
explicit or clean so you can imagine
what the words WTF stand for but the
patreon etc I want to know how I'm
actually
testifying these so let's keep this one
clean since is otherwise clean WTF by
Marc Maron is very very funny it's
basically roughly speaking celebrity
interviews right but Marc Maron is a
comic and a writer and an actor himself
and he's just really very good
interviewer he gets people to say things
so they don't otherwise say to tell good
stories to tell some jokes and to get be
light-hearted you know I don't want
listen to physics podcasts for the
obvious reasons that I've already
mentioned there are good physics
podcasts out there there aren't you know
there's still really plenty of room for
a really good podcast that does nothing
but talk about a big physic story every
week right like my podcast doesn't do
that maybe there are podcasts out there
that try to do that
but that I'm just not that familiar with
there are plenty of physics podcasts but
that's sort of you know look when I do a
podcast since this is not my day job I
do it because it's what I think is
interesting it's it's not like us my
primary goal is not to provide a service
I'd like to think that I am providing a
service and I think that that is a goal
but it's not my primary goal I'm not
that selfless I need to keep myself
interested right whereas if I were to
provide a service you know maybe you'd
be useful to do a like physic story of
the week podcast and I don't do that and
I'm not even sure there's a great one
that does it if there is then you know
please leave it in the comments because
again I'm not I'm not that familiar with
the podcasting space there are a lot of
good interview type podcast like what I
do
Cara Santa Maria has the talk nerdy to
me podcast that I've appeared on Ellie
Ward has ologies podcast where she talks
to a different ologist
every week so paleontologist
anthropologist and so forth Steven
Strogatz at quanta has just started a
podcast where he talks to mathematicians
and scientists and things like that so
there's a bunch out there and again I'm
almost hesitate to say to give any more
recommendations as I'm sure I'm missing
a lot of really really good ones you
know I like in the non physics realm I
like hardcore history
is another one that I really really
enjoy things like that things that are
taking my brain very far away from
physics jeremy Labrecque says if a
photon of wavelength X is traveling and
encounters a photon of the same phase it
results in constructive interference if
that photon meets the same photon half a
wavelength further it will be out of
phase will result in destructive
interference I thought that photons
don't experience time because they
traveled the speed of light but we get
two different outcomes when it
encounters the same photon in two
different positions what has changed
about the photon in that period so that
we get two different outcomes when
interfering with the same photon so one
thing I have to say first is that you're
speaking a language that kind of mixes
up photons which are particles with
waves of light which have wavelengths
and constructively or destructively
interfere of course these two things are
closely related to each other but it's
the quantum mechanical wave that is
really there the photon is a particle
that we observe in our detector so it's
better to speak I think a wave-like
language here now this idea that photons
don't experience time you know that is a
common language translation of a
technical fact the technical fact is the
proper time along an ultra jek turi a
speed of light moving trajectory through
space-time is zero okay that's the fact
the proper time is zero photons don't
experience anything but you know what
neither do electrons or protons their
elementary particles or at least the
electron is as far as we know that the
proton has some stuff some substructure
but it's still in a unique quantum state
it's not experiencing anything at all
the amount of proper time along the
trajectory for an electron is a positive
number whereas it is zero for a photon
but that is that mathematical statement
doesn't mean that time doesn't happen
the photon moves through space and we
who are not photons can still talk about
the photon at different moments of time
so when you say you get two different
outcomes when two photons encounter each
other at different positions well that
happens at different times from our
point of view once you're talking about
more than one photon you can't be in the
let's put this way when you talk about
two photons that are going to hit each
other okay you can talk about what is
seen in the reference frame of one
photon or the other but not both at the
same time if you're gonna be moving at
the speed of light you can pick the
center-of-mass frame in which case
they're both moving so in some sense
there is a change that happens to the
photon when it encounters another Photon
but at that moment of change it is no
longer moving quite at the speed of
light when one photons interact with
other things they're no longer moving at
the same speed
that's why photons move more slowly
through glass or water or air so then
time does happen even to the photons
John jack says as a grad student that
works on theoretical fluid dynamics I
have always been a bit jealous of the
attention fundamental physics gets with
the public I've seen a lot of people
that consider the theory of turbulence
and other theoretical problems with
fluid dynamics as a practical problem or
a problem to be left to the engineers
and modelers why do you think this is
the case so I would you know my
recommendation is easy for me to say so
you're welcome to ignore my
recommendation don't worry about how
much attention your field gets with the
public worried about how the work is
going right I mean you should worry
about funding that that's important if
if anything if you think that there are
aspects of your field like I say your
field because I'm not specifically
speaking of theoretical fluid dynamics I
mean any field out there no one ever
thinks that their field gets enough
attention so this is almost universally
true if you think that's true if you
think that the public is missing
something because there's all sorts of
really cool things about your field that
they could know but they're not getting
because the ecosystem is not giving it
to them then give it to them then you're
saying that there's a huge opportunity
there's a huge market out there for
interesting things about your field to
be shared widely and no one's doing it
so do it right if that's that's the you
should take that those lemons and turn
them into lemonade would be my advice
but my even bigger advice didn't not
care you know people think that certain
questions are interesting or less
interesting that's an that is a
subjective thing it's not like the
coarse graining on phase space that we
use to define
entropy that is extremely relative to
the individual interests and knowledge
of the person okay and that is going to
change as that person becomes more and
more educated in a field
it is perfectly understandable that
individual questions within some field
will have different levels of interest
to people in the field and people
outside the field once you learn more
about it once you learn more fluid
dynamics you realize oh there are all
these really important questions that
are fascinating and fundamental and I
like them and I say good for you
right if you can somehow get that across
to a wider audience then that would be
great but I wouldn't worry about it you
know I think again it's an opportunity
if you care about reaching those people
and if that's not your personal goal
which is perfectly fine then you know do
other things you know worry about
getting the work done
that would be my advice Bryce Graham
says I'm trying to understand the
following quote by Herman vile the
objective world simply is it does not
happen only to the gaze of my
consciousness crawling upward along the
lifeline of my body does a section of
this world come to life as a fleeting
image in space which continuously
changes in time I've heard the block
universe model of time described as a
music record just as the past present
and future are real the entire song
exists on the record however we only
experienced a single instant at of time
at a time just as the needle on a record
only plays a single note of the song in
this analogy what could be considered
our needle with respect to the block
universe
so yeah this I'd like both of these
analogies I think that vile gets it a
little bit more accurately here than the
needle analogy because the there is no
needle right that's the part of the
analogy that isn't working and this is
just gonna be a problem with analogies
that analogies are never perfect the
analogy of the record is the point that
there's a difference between what is
real which is the whole song on the
whole track of the record and what you
are experiencing at any one moment in
time so at any one moment you say okay
pick out a slice of the universe one
moment in time on that slice of the
universe there is a you
right there is one moment of your
existence and what is now with respect
to so sorry to ask you what is it this
is experiencing that moment of time is
now that part of you that moment of you
is experiencing the rest of the moment
of the universe as now there is no
needle though there's nothing outside
the universe that is pointing to that
moment and calling it special that's the
whole point of being an eternal a--
store block universe person is that all
of these things are real so the question
of what is now is always relative to
what is going on every individual moment
in your life experiences are different
now and that's fine I think that's fine
like I think I have a bed I think I'm
not very good at explaining this because
honestly I don't see the problem very
much
it seems pretty clear to me so I think
therefore I'm I'm missing some
disconnect between how I think about
this and how present is think about it
we need to get a present on the podcast
to really argue the sound Frank Cochran
says should further studies lead to the
over to overcoming the initial
skepticism from a new study using
analyzed data from the Chandra x-ray
Observatory observing a quasar at
approximately 1 billion years from the
Big Bang and suggesting that the cause
Marshall constant appears to have
changed during a subsequent
12.8 billion year expansion while
accompanied by large-scale and I satrapy
might that alter your thinking one way
or the other with regard to eternal
inflation Theory so I think I mentioned
the anisotropy claim before now I'm
worried I talked about anisotropy when
the question didn't ask about it because
I was thinking about this question ahead
of time if I did that sorry it's been
too long now too much my proper time is
elapsed since I answered that question
anyway I put very very low credence on
this anisotropy claim in cosmology we
have my gray background it's it's
isotropic you'll be very very hard to
imagine anything else now there are
observations that can change your
credence --is with respect to inflation
the eternalness of inflation is not
really very relevant here I think that
the experimental question is whether
inflation happened in our past light
phone or not eternal inflation is about
whether inflation is still going on
elsewhere
which is not really an experimental
question so I can imagine that there
would be observations but these
particular observations that you're
talking about again I just don't think
that they're very credible so we are
trying right now to do observations with
respect to potential gravitational waves
signatures in the microwave background
also with respect to what are called non
Gaussian ADIZ which are a way of
thinking about correlations between
different fluctuations at different
length scales in the microwave
background so far everything's very
vanilla and boring so we don't really
say anything one way or the other about
inflation but we're definitely trying it
definitely could be different kinds of
things and you know I'm responsible for
some of them you know some of the papers
I've written made predictions for for
example large scale and I saw trippy so
when I say I don't believe the claim
about large scale and I saw trippy that
is speaking against my own interest
since I predicted large scale and I saw
trippy but I predict that it should show
up in the CMB not in galaxies first trip
Denison says recently I started reading
Ian banks is culture series because you
often bring it up in discussions about
futuristic or conjectural sociology
economics AI I was expecting a cerebral
philosophical story but I've been
surprised by how brutally violent the
first novel is do you have opinions
about violence in fiction and media I
have opinions but I don't think my
opinions are especially clever or
profound I think that violence is fine
and I think that it can be overused you
know I think that I think about violence
about the same way I think about jump
scares in horror movies or sappy music
in romantic movies they can be
substitutes for real good storytelling
but they can also play a crucial
important role in good storytelling so
again I don't think it's a very clever
or deep way of thinking about it but I
think it's true
violence plays a role and so I you know
I don't mind the violence and thanks his
novels sometimes it gets pretty extreme
you know he has written non science
fiction novels he wrote a famous book
called the wasp Factory which is kind of
truly horrific ly violent and it's not
for everybody I don't actually recommend
it I used to recommend it cuz I really
really liked it and I found that people
were began to look at me funny
they're like you like that that's kinda
Oroville but then again there's other
examples like in a lot of Quentin
Tarantino movies I mean Tarantino is a
brilliant director in many ways and I
think that you know he has violence that
he uses in weird ways like to get laughs
and things like that which I kind of
don't like I think that violence can be
perfectly appropriate but it should be
appreciated for the horrible thing that
it is Antonio Justino says I would
appreciate some help better
understanding the fundamental qualities
of space and inflation or expansion
which have always confused me space
expansion accelerates between the
galaxies but not within one galaxy is
that because gravity keeps the actual
space fabric from expanding or because
gravity keeps the particles in relative
distance together while the fabric still
expands it's yeah it's I think that I
have to hesitate here because I'm not
sure there's a difference between these
two options so what the way that we
think about it in general relativity is
there is space okay and you can put some
coordinates on space and once you put
those coordinates on space you can use
those coordinates to talk about what we
call the metric and the metric is a way
of converting coordinates into physical
distances if you draw a path through
your coordinates you can use the metric
to figure out the length of that path
either length in space or the length in
time likewise you can figure out areas
and volumes and things like that okay so
it doesn't matter at all what
coordinates you use right so I can use
coordinates on space-time in which the
universe is not expanding at all or I
can use the coordinates in which so I
can use it coordinates in which the
universe is not expanding but objects
are shrinking right it's the same
difference it doesn't really matter so
you have to and then in this and I don't
want to act like this is easy or trivial
you have to shift your intuition a
little bit when you go from Newtonian
absolute space to general relativity you
have to figure out that there are some
questions that have sensible answers and
some questions that don't so the
questions with sensible answers are
what is the physical distance at some
particular moment in time between two
objects or how long would it take to zip
a beam of light from one object to
another and bounce it back and so the
question about you know if the universe
is expanding in between the galaxies but
not within the galaxy that's a poetic
way of again translating into English a
very specific claim about the metric on
space-time and the point is the metric
within a galaxy - a very good
approximation is static it's not that
different than the metric within the
solar system okay there's no need to
talk about expansion at all but if I
throw a particle away greater than the
escape velocity of the galaxy the
distance between me and that particle is
growing with time that's just true right
if so think of it this way if I were in
special relativity there's no gravity no
expansion of the universe I could
imagine a configuration of particles
which I started with them all moving
away from each other right so that would
look in that world just like space was
expanding and if you if you wanted to
ask but is space really expanding
because all the particles are moving
away from each other my advice would be
not to ask that question you know and
wonder about questions that have
physical answers so the distances that
you can measure on specific trajectories
or the times it takes that will be
measured by clocks on specific
trajectories or the redshift that you
see a photon undergo given what its rest
frame frequency was those kinds of
things have physical answers so there is
an intuition according to which space is
static near a galaxy is expanding in
between the galaxies but what really
matters is what you observe along
trajectories George Robinson says I'm
not sure that sorry
Antonio I'm not sure that was a
completely satisfying answer it's the
best I can do I've struggled with this
question for a long time George Robinson
says the many-worlds version of quantum
mechanics explains away some of the
mystery of measurement but what does it
say about the mystery of entanglement
given an entangled system we can
calculate the outcome of an experiment
but what can we say about the nature of
entanglement so I think that you have to
these are not the same thing there's no
there's no such thing as the mystery of
entanglement entanglement exists it's
perfectly well described we know
everything about it
it's surprising to us if we start from a
classical intuition but that doesn't
mean it's a mystery like we've figured
it out dang woman is not mysterious we
talk about the measurement problem in
quantum mechanics not because it's weird
or surprising but because we don't agree
on what is happening a many-worlds
person says the measurement process is
one in which a small quantum system in
superposition becomes entangled with the
environment a Copenhagen person says the
wavefunction collapses when something
makes a measurement so they don't agree
they're saying different things that's
the mystery there's nothing to say about
the mystery of entanglement except look
things are entangled that's what many
worlds has to say aurilla Biddle says do
you know what we're to expect to see in
fall of 2021 when we first start getting
images back from the James Webb Space
Telescope I'm very excited for this I'm
not really this is not my expertise so
I'm probably not the right person to ask
the thing about the Webb telescope is
that it is an infrared telescope so
unlike the Hubble Space Telescope that
was visible light where we're sort of
taking the same kinds of pictures just a
much better resolution than we take here
on earth with Webb we'll be looking at a
different set of wavelengths and the
reason why that's an interesting thing
to do is of course because things in the
early universe not the super early
universe not like one second of the Big
Bang but things at the early stages of
star formation and galaxy formation
their light has been red shifted from
when they were formed to today so the
thing that we're most excited about I
think generally with the James Webb
telescope is the ability to look at very
very old stars and galaxies to get an
idea of what was happening in the
earliest moments when galaxies and stars
first started existing when they started
forming more specifics than that you
will have to look up online that's
that's my general amateurs knowledge
Tony
chef ardougne says if we were given
power to magically solve or answer
anyone if I was at me i Sean were given
power to magically solve or answer any
one open problem or question physics
that currently defies our understanding
knowledge which one would
B&Y um I don't know am I allowed to say
what is the correct theory of everything
because if I'm allowed to say that I
will choose that I think that's pretty
that's a pretty good one it's not the
only one like even it wouldn't be the
final answer to every question you know
you still don't know things like how
complexity evolves in the universe and
stuff like that so just knowing the
theory of everything isn't good enough
but if I only had one question to ask it
would be that if that counts as too
grandiose than something like you know
yeah how do we reconcile quantum
mechanics with gravity that would be a
really good one I would like to know
that okay the final question of the IMA
is from Paul Hess who says in your Katie
Mac interview you said that you don't
believe there will be quantum
fluctuations in the far future because
there would not be an observer measuring
the quantum state of the universe why is
an observer necessary to affect whether
or not there are fluctuations for an
example wouldn't a Boltzmann brain
observe itself so you have to be careful
I'm not saying there are no fluctuations
I'm saying there no dynamical
fluctuations in other words the quantum
state doesn't change from one state to
another one
the phrase quantum fluctuations is not
very well-defined and the papers I wrote
with Kim body and Jason Pollak we
actually went through at least three
different things you might mean by the
phrase quantum fluctuations dynamical
Boltzmann fluctuations observer induced
fluctuations when you measure a quantum
mechanical system or radiative
corrections differences between
classical expectations and quantum
mechanical expectations so what we mean
is since there are no observers there
are no measurement induced fluctuations
in the early in the in the late universe
and also the wave function of the
universe settles into a static state so
there are no dynamical random
fluctuations either the state is static
that's what it means that there are no
fluctuations there are still radiative
Corrections which are just a different
way that says a very bad use of the word
quantum fluctuations so the Boltzmann
brain observing itself no I mean a
Boltzmann brains don't come into
existence in the late universe because
there are no random fluctuations going
on so it's the it's not the it's true
that there are no observers but that's
not the most important thing the most
important thing is the wave function is
static the wavefunction is not changing
with time so literally nothing is
happening in the very very late universe
at least according to me and Jason and
Kim that's what we think and we tried to
present the case some people agree with
us
some people don't it's one of those one
of those situations that I personally
come across surprisingly frequently in
my research where half the people are
like this is so obviously true why are
you bothering wasting my time and the
other half are like this is so obviously
false you've gone completely crazy so
that's where I like to live at that
boundary between obviously true and
obviously false someday I will achieve
that special place to live where you go
wow that is not obvious but it seems to
be true that's what we should all shoot
for all right stay safe be healthy out
there and talk to you later
bye bye
[Music]
you
[Music]